an eventful weekend special counsel
Robert molars investigation capped off
Friday with court filings involving two
of President Trump's closest campaign
allies in a heavily redacted filing
prosecutors said former Trump campaign
Chairman Paul Manafort broke his plea
deal by telling quote multiple
discernible lies to investigators
according to the court papers mana fort
lied about his contacts with Constantine
column neck an aide with alleged ties to
Russian intelligence prosecutors also
say mana Ford did not tell the truth
when he said he had not been in contact
with Trump administration officials
after the inauguration the mana for
filing came three days after Muller
recommended no jail time for the
president's former national security
adviser Michael Flynn and on the same
day federal prosecutors in New York said
the president's former lawyer should go
to jail Paula Reed has that part of the
story Michael Cohen was spotted in New
York shortly before federal prosecutors
told a judge he deserves a substantial
prison term in a case involving campaign
finance violations prosecutors did not
advocate for leniency because they
allege Cohen's crimes reveal a man who
knowingly sought to undermine core
institutions of our democracy in order
to profit personally the president's
former personal attorney had also been
cooperating in Special Counsel Robert
Muller's investigation into Russian
interference in the 2016 election in a
separate memo to the judge lawyers from
the special counsels office say Cohen
met with them seven times and provided
useful information about discrete Russia
related matters core to its
investigation they also reveal Russia
reached out to the Trump campaign as
early as November 2015 offering
political synergy and proposing a
meeting between Canada Trump and
Vladimir Putin in anticipation of the
filings President Trump on Twitter again
called the Special Counsel investigation
a total witch hunt he vowed to release
his own report to rebut Muller's
findings for CBS this morning Saturday
Paula Reid Washington seeking to
distance himself from both filings last
night President Trump tweeted totally
clears the president thank you they'll
make sense of these developments were
joined by Jesse Weber he
an attorney and anchor on the law and
crime Network Jessie good morning good
morning well let's start with the
president's tweet this is totally clear
the president's I would say no but let's
just take a step back remember whenever
we talk about Kohinoor metaphor nobody
cares about them right we all want to
know how this relates to President Trump
and more importantly the Russia probe so
I think we learned a lot of interesting
things also in relation to this Flint
sentencing memo at the beginning of the
week so if we start off with Cohen right
the first paragraph is he has overstated
basically the value of his cooperation
and the information that he has provided
and I have to tell you I wasn't
surprised by that I think a lot of
people expected that he was going to get
the same kind of recommendation as Flynn
no prison time yeah but what the
Southern District said is yes we can't
ignore the fact that he provided some
valuable information to the special
counsels office but he was incomplete he
is not a hero in this story he only came
forward because he knew he was going to
be indicted and that was a huge part to
consider one of the things in those
filings though was that the campaign
finance reform excuse me of the campaign
finance reform that he broke the law is
there that he broke I can speak this
morning but it tied it to Trump that
Trump was the one who directed that why
is that important that's important
because Cohen in his of memo that he
filed earlier he said that Trump was
involved now you see the Southern
District saying that the president Trump
coordinated and oversaw those payments
now that doesn't mean that he
necessarily will be found guilty of
anything because even if he knew about
it it's still a question of what was the
purpose of the payment and that becomes
a separate question but this is the
first time that I saw in a memo that's
actually tying him to this and that was
a big part to make there in terms of
those campaign finance violations
because those payments again to Karen
McDougal and stormy Daniels I can't
believe I'm actually seeing this in
these kinds of filings it's the first
time that we're seeing kind of Trump and
Cohen tied together in a filing by the
government and in terms of Manta fort
one of the documents outlines where he
lied how big of a blow is this to the
mother investigation since he was a key
witness it's a blow and I
tell you why it's a blow when you're
Robert Muller and you were building a
case a significant case like this you
were building it upon credible sources
and here he's saying he has lied about
five key areas now they're not directly
related to President Trump in the 2016
election but they may be and the thing
that caught my attention it was the
majority of the redactions were in
relation to that Russian spy Konstantin
Kim linic and the question is what is
his tie why would manna for make such an
effort to protect him and not tell the
truth because that's the question that I
had and you look at the other things
that he may have lied about and the idea
is is he V lied about this what else do
they have to question because there was
we're looking at everything that they
said he lied about but what about the
value of the information that he did
provide the Trump Tower meaning I didn't
see anything right right just whoever
thanks so much for being with us thank
you